hi so I'm here at the Apple Store um and
it's kind of cool because they have all
these clips of African safari on here so
I'm going to show you something here our
first clip we're going to cut to a lion
with flies on his face
okay so here's the lion and he has a lot
of flies on his face as you can see
there's one right there flying around oh
and his nose is so biggie actually if I
wanted to make my home I could probably
make my home inside of his nostril there
listen son we are having daddy son
bonding time look at this I know that
you might not be enjoying this but can
you at least put a smile on your face so
that everybody watching thinks that
you're having a good time and then I'm a
good dad ah my life
I think I enjoy sitting here by the
beach swaying back and forth I am a
hammock and I hate my life this sucks
can somebody please come here and sit on
me things I spent one of the holidays in
France and this is my brother this is my
brother we hung out and he played the
accordion it was so great he's really
good
and this is my other brother he likes to
dance
okay actually there's there's no
relationship whatsoever
ah
why
and that's a kid on a tire swing let's
see what else we got here I'm sick of
these little kids running around
no hey guys I'm just hanging out here I
got this little bug on my face I just
can't get rid of it I just I want Hey
Hey where's all my friends where's my
friends what are my friends doing oh hey
guys hey man we're just checking out the
scene here we're just hanging out here
on the Prairie man I'm having so much
fun I just don't even know what to do
hey guys you just don't like to be me
seriously you just have no idea it's
like a Walk and Walk and Walk and my
feet just keep on a hurting I'll see you
guys later I got something to do I
thought this was gonna be a fun vacation
and then my boyfriend left me and now
I'm here looking people waterfalls over
myself I hate my life I'm a cheetah in a
tree I'm a cheetah in a tree and a
cheetah
watch me pee I'm a cheetah Angie I'm a
cheetah in a tree
hippos are one of the most dangerous
animals in the African safari you need
to never get in front of the hippo and
the water look at those munchers it'll
kill you and that was my impression of
bear girls from Man versus Wilde I'm
gonna have to work on that one just a
little bit
hey dude where are we going man good
thing we have kleenex here because you
never know when you're gonna need it hey
can you pass back that toilet paper I
gotta go man I gotta go and that my
friends is a compilation of a bunch of
iMovie clips and my commentary thanks
bye
foreign